And let's um let's kick it off. Dex, how
was uh how was this last weekend? Oh
man, what a blast. Uh we still got to do
the post, but um had a lot of fun. Um
for those of you who who missed the
Well, we didn't post about it. So um we
did a eight hour AI that works workshop
where we went super deep on a lot of
advanced prompt engineering techniques
and um
built some 12 factor agents from
scratch. Um I think some interesting
takeaways for me uh one of the biggest
ones is like this thing that keeps
coming up which is like we don't need
bootstrap for agents. We need shad CN
for agents. We need like an open box
that you know yes you generate all the
code and then I own it and there's no
library like it doesn't I can't just
like upgrade the version and get new
stuff. I have to do it by hand. But I
think I think that's what people want
right now.
What was your favorite takeaway?
Um, I think I was surprised that 40
engineers stuck around on a beautiful
Saturday uh afternoon with the windows
outside and decided to listen to us talk
for uh eight hours rather than go
outside for a walk or do anything else
with their time. That was quite fun.
Um but um I really I think I really
liked what some of the people were
saying like this analogy that they were
starting to gro about Chad CN as well
about how what where we really need is
prompts that we control not prompts that
a library controls or framework controls
and that being like a really good
booster for being able to build these
kinds of things.
Awesome. Um cool. Well, I'm really
excited about what we're working on
today. Um, I guess we wait for a couple
more people to You want to start at like
10:05? I just shot you a link to the
whiteboard and two links.
Uh, which one is first or second?
Usually the second one is the public
one. Okay.
Yeah. I think the one that I'm really
really excited about today cuz like I
think uh usually we end up talking about
theory and today we're going to do
something very practical uh which is
we're going to start from a problem from
scratch and we're going to write a bunch
of code and I think the beauty of the
problem that we're tackling today is
that it's really not that much
code especially once you break down the
problem in the right
way. Um but shall we kick it off?
Uh yeah cool. So, do you want to set the
stage and describe the problem in
general?
Yeah. So, let me um I can share my
screen and kind of um walk through some
of this stuff. Um so, I'm going to pause
for one sec and just close a bunch of
Um so, um what we got is everybody hear
me? Okay, sounds good.
Audio is great. Um, let me switch and
see if I'm pretty sure for context. I
think one of the most common problems
that exists in AI is this problem that a
lot of people have which is like you
have some guidelines that you want
something to follow. So then you can
write an AI pipeline that mimics those
guideline that guideline evaluation in
some way and that was the theme of what
Dexter titled this talk which is like
policy to prompt.
Yeah. So essentially like one of the
biggest things that I think people are
doing a lot on in AI and there's a lot
of AI startups that are doing literally
just this which is like taking a set of
policies um and so this could be things
like FINRA this could be things like SEC
guidelines this could be things like
accounting laws in Europe
um basically anything where there's like
a big set of documents
Um, and so like one of these that we're
going to look at today is what's called
Sarbain Oxley, which like there's a
plain text version. You can just get it
from Wikipedia, but it's a bunch of
rules about like from like the early
2000s, I think, about like how do
corporations need to operate in order to
kind of be held accountable and, you
know, to keep their um all the crazy
rights that they get. Um, this was
published by the SEC in the early 2000s.
So like there's big sections of plain
text and like what are really really
good at is processing giant chunks of
plain text and turning them into
structured information.
Um, so what um what is a really common
problem is like you take a set of
policies and then you take a bunch of
evidence which is just like here's
something that happened and this can be
super generic and you put them together
and you say like for each piece of
evidence was the policy
followed? Um and you can output
basically a list of like
um
results that will tell you you know for
policy a section two yes policy A
section
three no and of course we have LM so we
can have some descript description or
something else right
um super common problem I've talked to
tons and tons of founders doing this
tons and tons of companies doing this um
people trying to use AI to do this. I
know some of the company that are making
like seven figures doing this as a as a
company. Yeah. Me and Vibob like to joke
that we're going to create uh a thousand
a thousand AI companies this year just
by showing people how to do some simple
stuff that's super super
valuable. Um not uh not not ourselves by
the way. You all have to take this and
go make something dope with it.
Um I think uh Dax one thing I want to
highlight here is like this general
problem space that we have of like you
have some policy you have some evidence
and you want to take the evidence with
the policies and analyze if it's
followed or not. Yeah.
How I guess like the most important part
is like what do what do you think is the
hardest part about this problem? Let's
start with that and then let's do some
whiteboarding of like system
architecture stuff and then let's talk
about it.
Um yeah, I mean so I think like the core
of this is like you have a piece of
evidence. Uh and let's make it more
concrete. What do you mean by evidence?
Uh so like the example we're going to do
today is going to be um we're going to
use the emails from the Enron data set.
Um, I don't know if anyone knows
quickly, but the story of Enron,
um, is that they were a big big company
and it turned out they were doing a lot
of really shady stuff and the entire
company fell apart and all the
executives were kind of like screwing
everybody over. Um, and then the company
died. And so the idea is the Enron email
data set, it was published by CMU. It's
a giant uh 1.7 g gig archive of emails
from sent by people at Enron. Um and so
you can come and see all these sent
messages. Um and you can see this. So
what we're going to do is kind of go
through each of these pieces of evidence
and say, "Hey, did did this email break
any rules?"
Does that track? Yep.
Um so this will be a fun one.
um still kind of poking around with
different sets of rules. But one thing
that um we were messing with was this uh
this is a 2004 code of conduct that is
published by JP Morgan. It has lots of
rules about uh talking about the
business publicly about um accepting
gifts and things like that about
publicly talking about finances without
disclosing you're an employee. Um I'm
not sure we're going to get out of this
but um we will we will try a couple
different things. So we'll pump Sarbain
Oxley and a couple other things through
here. Um, and the idea is not that like
today we're going to build a full end to
end demo. We're going to kind of like
build the architecture and then figure
out how and do it really naively to
start. Um, and so what we want to have
is kind of like extracting
uh kind of like from the policy you're
basically building a set of prompts,
right? And so like it for each Yeah,
let's write some code.
uh find uh violations,
right? We'll go we'll go Pythony here.
Um policies list of
string, emails list of
string.
Um and then this will be like a list of
results, right? And a result will have
uh what goes in the result of
um I think before we Yeah, we can write
this out really fast. The source email.
Sure.
um
some sort of identifier of the policy,
right? I don't know exactly how we're
going to if it's a pointer or if it's
the content or whatever and then it's
like
something like this. Yeah, I think
that's a pretty good um I think that's a
pretty good uh start. But I think like
before we even go go into this, let's
just like try and whiteboard a little
bit and just say like what kind of uh
diagrams do we actually have? So I think
when I look at this data the first thing
that comes to my mind is like what's the
data that we have available to
ourselves. So we have like the you said
the what what are those docs called that
you talked about you had two documents
specifically one was a plain text
document and then one was the one was
the one was a PDF. Yeah the JP Morgan JP
Morgan and then what's the other
document here? So beans exactly and I
think mo there's two different ways that
we could do this. The most naive way is
we put this into some context window. We
put this into some context window and
then we just ask the LM to do the dumb
thing and say okay is this is this uh
does this match the policy break policy
and there's probably a word world in
which like um where this
works where like you can actually take
this email ask it like literally just
ask the LM directly does this break the
policy and just get a yes or no. Yeah
but I don't think this will work with
most models today yet. So, we actually
have to break this problem down into a
different problem. And I think and I
actually want to say like we could even
go even bigger and we could say all of
the emails tell me which emails break
the policy and why. But you're already
skipping that one, right? Yeah. Yeah. I
skip that one. We can't send all the
emails. So, we say for a single email,
here's the entire policy. What's the
email? This is what we always talk
about, right? is like if you can solve
the problem slowly and expensively at
the start but you know it's possible
then you can go grind it down and try to
do something more focused. Exactly. So
now what I would say is instead what if
we could break down the plain text into
a bunch of
policies and then go ask oh I see. So we
have the ability to go and take this
whole thing and break it down to a bunch
of unique policies and then ask
questions about each policy in
parallel. we will probably get slightly
better answers and even over here we can
actually use like a single prompt to go
do all this like we don't technically
need different prompts
um where we ask it for every single one
um and just ask it which of these did we
break and we kind of know exactly what's
going on you're talking about single
prompt as in like ask it to reason
through 20 policies first and then
produce it answer well once we have a
list of policies and doesn't really
matter how we did this step. I should I
should be clear on this. Oh, when you
say Yeah. When you say single prompt,
you mean one prompt where we just have
template in the policy and template in
the evidence. So the input to this
prompt is the policy description and
then the and the email and we just ask
it does this does this email break this
policy? So that's one thing that we
could go do. Uh right. So I'll break
this out later. um t so like defaf
um check policy will take
in we'll take in like an
email stir and a
policy stir and literally just return a
boolean y that's what each of these do
but I think that this is actually not
going to end up working as well for most
systems so instead what I would what I
think we could do wait why
um one because the nuances of the policy
will probably get lost on the system a
lot. So like for example uh we worked at
some fintech companies and like one of
the things that comes up is
like the word asset means something
completely different in the context of
different financial
companies and even extracting the
terminology of that word asset is really
really really hard.
Okay. Right. Because in some companies
like like if you're in like macro uh in
like doing like macro uh macro trading
then like assets can include like oil
fields or like uh like like a bond that
you have on an oil field or something
else. But if you're in like a and the
word crypto like what do crypto what
does crypto mean in the sense of assets?
It we really don't know. So I actually
think to do might actually be to go even
further and say in fact we're actually
not going to pick every policy. We're
only going to pick some of
them. And for now, instead of being
really good at detecting every policy
break, we'll pick a couple policies that
we know are critical and go specific
uh and I'm going to name these now.
Policy A, policy B, and go build
specific um pipelines for policy A and
policy B
uniquely, if that makes sense.
Cool. So these might have their own
custom prompts and it's not just
templating in two strings and saying
like does this match. Yeah. And they
might even have more than just a prompt.
They might have a whole pipeline
for each one if that makes sense. Cool.
Yeah, that makes sense. Um I'm wondering
if it might make sense just to
demonstrate kind of like really simply
and like testing and prompts like what
what this naive way looks like before we
go start and do the advanced stuff.
Yeah, let's do it. So like just just to
quickly just so we have something to
build from like let's go from like here
let's do like evaluate
policy and we would just say
like email
string policy string.
Um, and we actually we built another
pipeline already or I I was hacking on a
short pipeline that is basically just
extracting questions. And so like read
through a giant policy document and
extract a list of kind of like policies.
I think VIB made a really good point
which is like if you use a bunch of LLM
generated inputs, you're going to get
lowquality LM generated outputs. But
like here's an example of like what this
might look like. Um, so you could take
this question and ask, you know, of this
email what what what was there? Um, but
that's just kind of framing the shape of
this. Um
and compare them
to pieces of email evidence, right?
Yep.
Your goal is to determine whether the
email evidence violated the policy,
right? Yep.
Here's the email.
Say
email policy
say, you know, I would actually put the
policy in the system prompt. Okay, cool.
Um,
We'll just have one. Uh maybe we should
return an array of violations.
Even though we're only going to do one
policy.
Yeah, one policy at a time with a bunch
of
um and then I would also list out like
uh Yeah, we can do
that. I would put the reason before the
reasoning.
Oh, sorry. I put the result before the
Yeah, there you go. Okay. Why is that?
Well, let's let's let's just run it.
We'll try. We'll flip it around. We'll
see see how it affects the output,
right?
Um, so the email let's just grab one of
these. You can just grab one of these
and run
And then the policy would be something
like members must not accept gifts. And
then one more hashtag at the end. Yep.
Oh, other way. Swap it.
Oh, really? Oh, sorry. It's like this.
Yeah. Sorry. Since I highlighting on
your color scheme doesn't work for my
brain.
bull. All right, here we go.
Uh, just hit command. Yeah, I think if
you hit command S on the file, it should
load for you. I'll figure out why for
you specifically. This seems to be a
problem.
Um.
Oh, do I need to? No, you should. I
already updated this. You can just open
it. Can you hit run
test? Just say command S. Yeah, there
you go. Just say command S on that file.
Uh, this is odd. There you go. There we
go. All right. Here we go.
So result false reasoning not accept any
does not discuss any acceptance of gifts
or favors. Yeah.
Um okay. So that's kind of the the shape
of it though. Um let's write a test. Uh
and then I think the the thing about
reasoning is like um there's a couple
kinds of things that we could go do.
Uh, shouldn't you before? Um, it depends
on what you're trying to go do. Uh,
sorry, there's a couple questions uh
that people are asking. And I realized
Oh, yeah. I did not have my chat window
open while I was looking. Um, Kosal
asked, "Wouldn't you say in the system
prompt uh what you are working with to
avoid that you don't know an asset?" and
cush that that's that's true. But if I'm
building something that analyzes all of
the Enron data sets, then you can do
equal equals instead of just
result. Yeah. Uh if I'm analyzing
something that analyzes the entire Enron
data set and that ends up being really
hard because uh like well in the world
of Enron there is no crypto. But you can
imagine that in today's if I'm a large
asset manager that sometimes I'll have
crypto, sometimes I won't. It's very
conditional. So you can actually like
hardcode that in uh cursor rule files.
There is one I can share that in a bit.
Um can we do contextual aware
decomposition for the policies and only
check with relevant policies and
exactly? So Deborah exactly so we don't
actually want to go do all the policies
but you're still going to have to build
some pipeline that predicts which
policies are relevant to this. And
there's different ways that we can go do
this but at some point we can use an lm
per policy. We can do like some sort of
selection with some sort of embeddings.
We can do like the ability to turn on
and off policy A and B and whether we're
running A or B could be another
prefilter step that we choose to run to
decide which of the policies are even
relevant for an email. Yeah. Like this
break policy A doesn't have to call an
LLM. It could have a step that says is
policy A relevant for this email and if
it is then we'll then we'll try it out.
Okay. So basically in our find policy
violations we would first do
like
filtered policies equals filter.
Yeah something like that becomes an
option that we can go do. And then Kyle
asked the problem um
uh Kyle asked a problem for um like
shouldn't we put the reasoning before
the result? It depends on what you want
to go use the reasoning for. So in this
case, what I would want to go do is I'd
probably want to show the reasoning to
the user about like what we did. But
what I would actually here Can you go
back the other prompt? You want to go to
the code? Yeah. What I would do is like
I would add one more thing above result
uh above. So and then that's like uh
like um relevant snippets.
Ah yeah string array. Exactly. And
that's going to be snippets of the email
that might be relevant to the policy
that and then what I would say that are
that I would say that may be relevant
specifically. I'm going to use the word
may so it's more permissive. Yeah. And
then I would go run this prompt and you
can just see how that this works.
Yeah. Um cool to find a way. Do you have
any um any hacks on uh how we might go
through this seven gig 1.7 gigs of
emails and find some that are
interesting? I would grap for gift
That's what I would do. I I there
might be one which because Enron
um and that might be the fast way to go
find something or I would just make a
test case that like is like artificially
there and then eventually we can just go
run this in a massive AWS job.
Yeah, that was the other thing. I was
like, it would be interesting to talk
about kind of how do you scale this
thing, right? How do you actually just
go fan out to hundreds of emails in
parallel? Well, the problem you'll first
run into is rate limiting. Um, yeah. Oh,
nice. I
saw a gift card is what I saw.
There's a lot of um there's a lot of ads
in people's email. I think these are all
like spam emails selling people [ __ ]
I mean that's fine. Share it in gift.
you can just copy and paste one of
these. It doesn't have to be everything.
It just has to be part of it. I think we
should just go and write as much as we
can. Oh yes, you are a command line
copier which is makes sense.
Uh, I can't tell if you're complimenting
me or talking [ __ ] but I'll take it.
Yeah. And there's there's interesting
things in here, too. So, like there's
clearly emails that
um Oh, it's going to copy and paste all
this. I would just Yeah, using an LLM
for copy paste is really uh is really a
great is a great approach. Like write it
yourself.
Yeah.
it
doesn't cool I think you have too many
curies at the bottom.
Oh, they were already there.
Yeah. Let's try this one.
Result true.
Um, so it pulled the relevant snippets.
Result true. And then we have our
reasoning here. Yeah. And like we can
just skim this email really fast just to
make sure. I think it's useful to
actually read it because like no matter
what we do fundamentally at this point
like the LM is going to go do this.
Yeah. So let's read
this. So clearly this person did not
receive a
gift. This person sent a gift which is
very different than receiving a gift.
And this is exactly what I was talking
about. Having a general policy system
that does this won't capture the nuance
of the actual policy.
Yeah. And that's going to make it hard
to actually build a good pipeline.
Okay. Like this is like a clear example
of what's going on. So here's how I
would attack this problem in a little
bit. Instead of going for this directly,
I would say we're not going to build a
system that evaluates a policy. We're
going to build a system that evaluates a
gift
policy because I don't want to suddenly
flag people
uh for actually like not uh for not
actually Yeah, there you go. I don't
want to suddenly flag people for uh
giving gifts, not getting gifts. Now,
there might be something illegal that we
do evaluate gift policy is probably what
we want.
Yep.
Yeah, exactly. So, and what I
really exactly what I really want to do
is I might even put the text of the
policy in there myself if if it's
useful.
Um, yeah, there you go. Uh, we don't
need the policy parameter going into
this. Yeah. Um, and then we the
violation is going to be slightly
different. Um, so can I ask for remote
control? Yeah, go for
it. You're supposed to figure out the u
code remote screen sharing thing, but go
for it. All right, you're in. So, this
is kind of how I do this. Instead of a
violation, I'm do like class
email gift email
analysis. Uh, and I'll say like uh type
um
received gift given. Yeah,
um sender will be like the sender of who
it is. We don't actually need to see
this.
um sender
company and specifically what I mean to
say when I say sender and is like um
risk uh I see okay so you're kind of
hard coding the exact reasoning steps
you want the model to take into the
structured output
exactly um and then specifically what I
want to do is like recipient
Um
yeah.
Um all right, cool. Recipient. Uh what I
really wanted to hear is like recipient
uh company.
Yeah. What I really wanted between the
sender
and let me write this out. Oh, can you
do sender and the company?
Not company. Yeah, exactly. And then
same thing down
below. Exactly. And now make that again.
What is the What is the company? I feel
like that's gonna be Oh, yeah. But at
the top, put like
company. I I may want to pass in the
company as a parameter into line 13 as a
as a as an input. No, we may not even
want that. Actually, we may not want
that. We're going to send it like as a
parameter like uh the as parameter on
line 13. Yeah. Let's send in the company
name.
Exactly.
I mean, if I know is it the So, the
company name in this case is Enron or if
it's the the other party. Exactly.
Enron. You Okay. So if I'm doing this on
behalf of and on line 18 you'd say on
behalf of
uh on line 18 you're combined on behalf
of Yeah. Exactly. So now you
just exactly
working at Yeah. Sure. Yeah. Okay. Um,
so this is cool, but I want to throw
another sticky one your way, which is
like um I think what's what's probably
tricky is like figuring out which policy
this is and generating good test cases
with real data. Um, because what I want
to do before we like do any more
optimizations of the pipeline, I want to
do what we talked about last week, which
is build a really simple end toend eval
um, and kind of build out that golden
data set. I know I know that's kind of
ends up being a lot of manual work, but
like is there is there ways we can build
kind of the pre-processing pipeline to
kind of set up based on what we have
here um and kind of do a parallel search
through all this stuff to try to find
that? Well, like one of the first things
we said last time was the most important
thing to do here is going to end up
being like some sort of like a vibe
eval. So, I just want to get a feel for
what that was. Like you notice how it's
just like putting a gift in there from
last time when we did when we did that
gift email. The first thing we noticed
like oh this is a clear bug because
started happening was can can you bring
that test case over?
The first thing we noticed that this was
a clear bug. Oops. Uh because this was
the bug here wasn't actually the fact
that everything was wrong. It's just
that this is like a
Exactly. So now let's try running this
really fast. I just want to see what
ends up happening.
Yep. And just hit command S again or
press enter or
something. There you go.
great. That's great. So like the first
thing that this did is it actually was
able to figure out that this was a gift
given from Kathy to uh the third party
business and the risk level is medium
right it could be risky because Enron is
not Enron employees are not supposed to
give gifts to people and like maybe
that's why the previous system said true
but we can go into this much much better
um and we can figure out like why we
might want to go do
like maybe this is a charity, maybe this
is something else. Um, so my manual
thing, the first thing I would do in
this one is like go I'm just going to
throw something out for later or maybe a
follow-up episode, which is like we
could do a follow-up of like turning
this into something a lot more agentic,
which is like, hey, what what follow-up
research tasks might you want to make
before you to get all the context for
evaluating this? And that might be like
read this email and see like, oh, I want
to go do a web search of Kinder Morgan
and see who that is. Because that's what
I would do as a human. I would be like,
who the heck are these guys?
Exactly. So like that's one way to make
it super agentic where you just go and
scrape the data and you can go do that.
So what that means is we might actually
want what you were adding earlier which
is the company names into all of
them. So let's add company names. Uh or
like maybe we had a recipient type first
of all.
Yeah. recipient type uh would be like
what like and let's say like let's call
that like client supplier other let's
make a type called entity
yeah so then now we'll do entity we'll
make an entity type at the
bottom exactly like this yes
I would say I would say entities might
be like
individual I would I would probably say
individual corporation.
Oh, I see. Or Yeah. Okay. Right. Or like
charity.
Uh because like we know in gifts like
these are probably like three kinds of
things that are involved. And now let's
try test case
Yeah, it sounds like the um the person
that received it is detecting as an
individual, which makes sense because it
was given on behalf of the per Can you
read the email again?
Yeah.
So, what's weird is this is like a
multiple thread, right? This was sent to
a [ __ ] ton of people at
Enron from it was like
forwarded by Kathy
Mayfield and it looks like Bill was
thanking Kathy for the gift
and then I decided to donate he further
donated the gift to a different center.
Yes. Right. So it's like a three-way
hop. So what that's interesting because
it goes from Enron to Kinderborg which
then went to another children's center
and you could completely see how um this
actually will
um effectively require additional
followup to actually go and like track
this down and find the relationship
between Bill and Kathy.
Yep. Right. So I think the first thing
that I really recommend that you're
seeing here is like what we're doing
here is we're reading the email and
we're just analyzing the test case one
thing at a time. We're not trying to if
we go and straight build the eval, we'll
kind of get lost in the sauce. Yep. What
we really should do is just read some
data. And like here, I think we've
collected probably enough information to
then say like there's not much more we
can get out of this email. Everything
else that we do would be a follow-up
based on the reasoning that comes out of
it. Yeah. You might want to Can you go
up one more step
after? Yeah, we can do like next next
steps after reasoning.
string array. Yeah.
Or like follow-up steps, right? Yeah.
Follow up actions. Yeah, sure. And I
would put that after
and like action could even be like
basically like a this could tr turn into
like a list of tool calls to do.
Exactly. Can you put it after reason
though? Oh yeah. Yeah. Now press
play. Cool. We can do that, too. Yeah,
let's go
there. Cool. So, that looks good. And
then you're right, we could turn that
into actions that are more oriented or
we could pass it into a secondary agent
like pipeline that has to go deal with
that. Um, but I think this is kind of
where I would um stop and just say,
okay, now I have a thing that's pretty
good. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, so, so do
you want to write some Python code here?
Write some Python code now. Okay,
cool. So, um, I'm going to make a new
file.
So, let's just assume what we're going
to get is an email input.
Yeah. Sorry. Let me um pop back up here.
Dude, you got to keep your extensions up
to date. Your uh rough is also out of
date. It's We don't use type checking in
this house. I'm actually going to turn
it off just to trigger you. Oh my god.
Yeah. There we go. Don't do that. Don't
do that, please. All right. All right.
All
right. Um, we don't even you can ignore
the if main or whatever. It doesn't
matter. Okay, cool. Um, so now that what
we'll do is we'll get let's assume we're
going to get a single email,
Sure. Yeah. I was in we don't even have
to read the email, but yes, we can do
that if we want.
Well, because I I would eventually like
to build up some stuff that lets us just
like grab a random email. Like, we're
not going to be able to do the whole
set, but Okay, that's fine. Uh, yeah.
mail people talking [ __ ]
Okay. Um,
or do you want to read that exact that
exact one with Doesn't matter. I I just
want something. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Cool. Great. So, we're going to read an
email and then here's kind of what I
would do as we read these emails. Yeah.
So, Oh, I mean it kind of that cool. Um,
and then you have to import B. There you
go. Oh, my cursor is getting quite good.
Okay. So, this is actually not going to
work because our gift policy makes an
assumption that there is a gift thing
built into it. This was I think uh
someone's question earlier like
Deborah's question. We probably want to
we probably want to ask a very simple
question like is a gift involved? Yes or
no. Gotcha. On so that's right another
model. Sorry, you have to open. Yeah.
So, we can just do like
function mentions gift with gift
involved. We don't even have to like
mention that. We could have like rejects
the word gift.
Okay. Right. Like let's do we'll make it
a Python function for now. Yeah.
Exactly. There you go. And then we'll
just do
that.
Exactly. And now we have analysis on the
emails. And now we basically have like a
gift pipeline that is able to go check
this.
Gotcha. Right. Um and then you probably
want an else
statement. if else or if return. Yeah.
Yeah. We we'll just return. Very cool.
Um and this is kind of what I would do.
And now we have a system that is able to
go from like not knowing if GIFs exist
to where we can probably find all the
policies where GIFs are involved and the
risk is high.
like exactly. And I would only print out
those analysis and I would print out
like the email path for those emails. So
I what what that's why I was trying to
write the function that does this not
like the whole pipeline because if we
have a function then we can wrap it
around a pipeline that passes in an
email. Yeah. Yeah. Um
Uh you want to make it async then you
have to do uh async client on line two.
Oh yeah. Um
yeah and then
yeah line two needs to
change. Line two needs to change. Oh you
want to just do async. Yeah exactly.
Cool. Cool. Uh, and then you have to
import
async.io. Cool. Let's try
it. Um, all right. We'll just run it
from
wrong. Yeah, this is kind of the goal,
Andrew, for this time. Usually we do a
lot of theory but our goal this time was
like let's start from nothing and
actually build up the pipeline
right so while D for so one of the
things that email does not mention on
gifts cool let's put a freaking for loop
around it and just run it on everything
so before you do that this LM thing is
going to blow out the water so don't
actually like run on LM just like
exactly
iterate over every email and just go run
it when you go do that so I'll show you
how to go do can I take over
[Music]
Um, sure. Okay, go for
it. Want to write some cursor code.
That'll probably work. It's They're not
as star.txt. They're just like number
dot is the thing.
Um, okay. And then it was like read.
It's like starst star.
Okay. So I just asked cursor to write
the code then. Okay. Sorry I can't type
under. Yeah. Yeah.
Isn't it path? Isn't it just pathstar
slar?
that. Wait, I don't think it has. Oh.
Oh, I guess that does
work. Okay, then. No, then don't you?
No, you're passing the path already.
That's why that that's why it does it
that way.
Say that again. You're passing here. Let
me tell you. You got it.
Can you turn off Vin mode for me,
please?
[Music]
[Laughter]
star path. Okay,
great. Is file. Then we just append it.
We load it in.
That's probably going to blow up memory
because it's like 1.8 gigs. 1.8 gigs is
nothing. Uh, okay. What we'll say is
like I got a very old MacBook over here,
buddy. Okay. talking 2022
than
uh
10,000. Okay. How about this? Yeah.
Yeah, let's do that. All right. So,
we'll load emails from Dur and then what
we'll do is like we'll say
like
dev that should be easier. So I'll do is
for every email and
io check emails
then you don't need this anymore. Look
no I do I do I do need this. Oh you just
need the first part. Yeah. Okay, we're
going to do this, but I'm not going to
actually run this because what else I
want to do is this is the other thing
people forget to do, which is um sele
Four.
Perfect. We're going to do this. And
then what I'm actually going to do is
I'm just going to return
false, right? Because you want to
collect the results. Exactly. And return
true. So, I'm going to return this
because I don't actually want to trigger
the LM yet. If I trigger the LM, I'm
going to be
closed. Uh, and what I want to do here
is equal to
results equals this. And then I want to
return results or return the results.
count. Oh, cool. Now that should do it.
So, now I can go do this. Um, the reason
I don't want to trigger the LLM shortly
yet is because I am going to run 10,000
emails here. We're going to be sitting
here for minutes if we're in end up uh
in this loop. So, I just want to get a
proxy for what my data has before I go
and execute it in a meaningful way. Um,
this is going to run up to 10 in
parallel. That's why I did async.io.
Oh, 44. Pretty fast. Cool. So, that's
fine. We can 44 emails. We can go
process. We can use an LM for this. This
isn't going to be a big deal. So, let's
actually turn on the LM. But before we
do that, um, so now we know that this
isn't Can you Can I go back to the code
again? Yep.
Okay. So, this is great. And
specifically, I'm going to start
changing this to return a nonobject
instead. Sorry, I have my Zoom. And this
is like an optional of analysis that it
returns. Exactly.
I can do that. Uh, wait one second. It's
on option on office. Let's be very
clear. Uh, this is going to be I'm only
going to return high risk levels. Yep.
Can you can you make that uh can you
return sorry can you return analysis if
the risk level is high? Yes.
Yeah. Otherwise return none. Exactly.
And then actually can you do can you do
can you can you uh you have to import
it. Yeah, there you go. Can you do me
another favor and it return if it's high
or
medium? There you go. Cool. Uh let's run
the sucker.
Looks like we had a validation error.
Okay, so we should try catch that
because this will happen at some
cadence. Why did this actually go look
at this? Oh, there's no there's no gift
received. Um, so that's true. Sometimes
there is no gift. Can you go up and read
this? Oh, yeah. You can turn it on.
Um, so let's take a email. It looks like
the model had no gift received. The type
was null because it probably to find
gift received or gift given. Oh, I see.
Right. It's like what did it return?
Let's go down and read. It tells you.
No, this is just the prompt. Yeah, but I
want to read the prompt and see what it
said. The model returned a null value
for that. Yeah. Gift receiver gift
given. Or I mean it might have returned
something that doesn't match this en it
said null. The model returned null. You
can read it up there. Okay.
See? Got null. Got null. Got null. Got
all. Can you go down? Oh, here's what we
responded. Okay, cool. Exactly. Can you
go down? Let's just read the email
really fast and skip. Um because Okay,
so our gift check passed, right? We did
is if if gift in email was true, but the
model decided this isn't about a gift.
Yeah, exactly. Which makes sense because
we used the reax.
I was God's gift and made sure I knew it
constantly, which makes sense. Okay,
cool. So, okay, let's just put a let's
allow the model to say like not a gift.
So, let's return two types. What was
either not a gift class not a gift?
Yeah.
Exactly. Done. Um, and then union the
result. No, we don't need that. We don't
need that either. Union the result.
Exactly. Now, let's go back to our code
and say if should we put Should we put
this one first?
No, it uh yeah, sure. Yeah, actually.
Yeah, it'll probably be because like
it's a smaller object, right? Yeah, I
agree. I agree. Let's go back and then
let's go back to the code. No, we don't
want to run this yet. You have to
actually Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Um pipeline.
So, just say like if if analysis
type analysis
type Yeah, exactly. Return none. Done.
Cool. Now we've given the model an
escape hatch. Exactly. Um, yeah. So, how
long will this take? I don't know.
There's like 44 emails. 44 seconds would
be kind of what I estimate, but I'm
running 10 in parallel. So, like I'd
estimate like around like the like 10 15
seconds, no more. Yeah. Okay. So,
basically, we have all of our emails and
then we have emails. I'll put it I'll do
top to bottom. is like a much smaller
set of those is like contains gift
string and then some subset of those are
going to be like not a gift. Yep. And
then some of them are going to be, you
know, analysis results. Yeah. But now
while we're waiting, let's go back. And
then these are going to be low, medium,
high. Exactly.
Oops. Oh, can we go back to our code? I
didn't realize that we Hold on a sec.
I'm gonna just uh obviously 44 out of
10,000 is not visually described by
this, but uh
um yeah. Well, no, I messed up because
if you go back to the code, yeah, you're
sorry. If you go back to the way that we
actually count it, the counter is not
correct. We say if it's true. See how
there's a static analysis there? Um
yes. Uh exactly.
Uh, exactly. And exactly. That's what
you actually need to do. Uh, and this is
one of the reasons that I'm really
excited to go like
um um this is why I'm Oh, and then I
would do like lend tasks for the first
one.
Exactly. Oh, yeah. That's great. And
then for the first one, can you do Yeah,
that's great. High, medium. And then can
for the first one instead of sum can you
just do like len len of tasks. Yeah
exactly. Um you can do not none just
like len tasks
Yeah because that's how many
things we have.
Um
so that's how many mentions. Oh no
you're right.
I think we need to filter by none. Yeah.
Yeah, you're
right. What does check gift email do?
Wait, what does check gift email do? Oh,
gift email does the whole thing. Yeah,
exactly. Okay. Yeah, you're right.
Sorry, your old code was right. I'm I'm
silly.
Yeah, I think that's right.
Cool. So, I just go run this. And like
one of the things here, this is why I'm
really really excited to work on caching
for us is Oh, you want to turn off the
logs. You do not want the logs on.
One of the reasons I'm excited to work
on caching is actually because of this
fact where it's like you saw that the
thing that we're actually modifying was
actually not everything else. What else?
So we got another error.
Ah entity type is unknown. It's because
we didn't give if you go back to the
entity
type data type. Ah it wants to have an
unknown.
Exactly. You put other, but other still
implies that it's
known, right? So, we might it might
prefer the word unknown over anything
else. Yeah. I notic this a lot with some
of the other like random you use like
deepseek and and quen some of them are
not as good at following the exact enum
instructions. Exactly.
And then we might actually find that hey
at some this is again something that
we're doing right now but we might
actually just want to put a try catch
around this pipeline because it doesn't
matter if we ran all of them or not. We
just need to be pretty good. Oh that's
kind of cool. We found four high risk,
five low risk by medium risk. Yeah. By
medium risk. So I think this is kind of
interesting. So can we do one one thing
Dexter? Do you have your API set up for
your dashboard?
Uh sure. Running this every single time.
Um, yeah. Yeah. Fire it up and send it
over to there. Yeah. Let's uh let's grab
an API key because the problem that
we're going to run into is we're
basically going to start like running
everything back and forth and I kind of
just want to look at this data more and
more. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And there's two
options that you can have for this. You
can actually build serialization by
default. This and this is that's what I
do with most of these pipelines is I'll
just dump out the JSON after every step
of like the collection of objects just
so you could go and inspect it. But this
is probably an easier way to do it. So,
let me get a key real quick and then
I'll start sharing again. Okay. Oh, you
stopped sharing. I was wondering why it
stopped. That makes sense.
Yeah. And I think this is this iteration
loop that we're doing right over here is
really the iteration loop that I see
most people doing. And at the end of
this, what we'll have is we'll have a
way to go through this. Oh, nice. You
shared anyway. Okay. All right. We'll
cycle that key. It's fine.
Uh, you still have to record. Wait,
control Z C. Do me a favor. Yeah, go to
your code. I'm just gonna make it easier
to go see. Uh, pipeline uppi. Are you in
Vim mode again? Disable that sucker. Oh,
you want to trace the whole thing? Yeah.
So, I just want to like have that in
there.
It does. It works automatically though.
It does.
You just want to group them in a single
single trace.
Um, cool.
Um, that's really the main thing that I
wanted to do. I just want to group
everything because it just makes
everything way easier to read. You can
just see it all in one run. Okay, cool.
Done. All right, let's ship
it. Let me just make sure this is
working. All right, good.
Yeah, it's a little bit bigger. Like
caching is like one of the things that
caching and mocking are one of the two
key things that every LM developer will
need long term because like what most
people mostly notice whenever we do this
is we spend very very little time
actually writing the AI part. We spend
most of our time writing the Python
part. Right? And so what you have is
like you have Python code and then you
have LM LM prompts and then you have the
LM, right? And what you want to do is
you want to test this
and say, "Okay, if I run this prompt
with this data, I get this result."
Exactly. And then separately, you want
to test this without having to round
trip to the LLM to test your Python
code. Exactly. And so, you want to
basically mock on this side and over
here you're going to mock on this side.
And you say, "Okay, here's fake data
that I know is in our pipeline, and over
here it's here." Yeah, exactly. And you
need to make this swappable really,
really easily. And ideally, I don't even
want mocking. I want like record replay
because most people don't have good data
sets that they're going to build over
time. Yep. I really want to and then be
able to like immediately know when I can
and cannot catch this. Okay, cool. Now
the data is done. Let's go look at it.
Okay, cool.
Just refresh. Can you just refresh
command R? Yeah. What was the pipeline
called? Let me just see what Let me go
see which project it's in. I don't
remember which project we put it in.
Yeah. All right. Good. Look at the ID
7543.
Do you have it? Do you want me to go do
it? Hang on. I'm just going to uh
I got it. Okay, so this should be the
project. I'm not sure why they didn't
just change the
filters. That's
tough. And it's like last 30 days or
something. Um, did it make it through?
Maybe it
didn't. I set a new key and I'm running
it again right now. So now we should
have
Huh. Oh,
Yeah, we don't have this yet. Yeah,
that's odd. Um, is your SAS working? I
have no idea. It doesn't matter. Let's
just run it with terminal really fast. I
don't really care. We should We really
just want to have it running. And I
think that's the most important part.
Yeah.
Um, yeah. No, it should be sending the
data up. I suspect the No, we're in the
middle of migrating the old thing to the
new thing. Um, but let's go ahead and
just look at some of this data and just
see what you want to just dump stuff out
to JSON or dump it out to a file. All
right, cool. That was going to be my
suggestion. Anyways, um, save everything
that is not none into a file.
Like they're listening to you.
Um, but there is one difference that I
want. You'll notice that this is the
part that uh Yeah, but don't do that in
there. One second.
Uh what is f? Oh, I see. Yeah, save save
that. And then what we also want I would
save every single individual email as a
duplicate into that file as
well. So what I this is where actually
most people mess up when they go do
this. So can I go do this one time?
Uh I got it. Well, I I want everything
to be in a unique file.
Oh, every single email. Exactly. because
it's going to be impossible to go read
in a giant JSON blog. It's basically
going to be useless. And I would
specifically want them in two separate
files.
The email and the analysis email and
analysis in a separate file uh that's
just like indexed by order in some way.
It's code that we don't write anymore.
I don't know,
man. Okay. Uh high risk.
Does that look right? Let me just do
this off the top of my head. It's going
to put in either the high-risisk or the
lowrisk folder. And then that's going to
email and then the Okay, cool. That
looks great. Let's go run this. Yeah.
And the reason I'm doing this is for a
couple of reasons, but the primary one
is just that what I really want to have
access to over here is I want to be able
to look up this stuff really, really
fast and make my iteration loop super
super fast.
And if I don't do this, like if I didn't
do the small stuff of making this
parallel, our iteration loop here
wouldn't be 10 seconds. It'd be a
minute. And that would Yeah. So let's go
back. It's changing. I wonder if it's
using a different set of emails also.
No, probably not. Um but all high risk.
Yeah. So So here's our email. Exactly.
So we can actually see what's end ends
up going on here is we actually can
really quickly You saw how fast you
navigated to that. Oh, this is
cool. Just by picking up 10,000 random
emails, we found a bunch.
Yeah. And like what does it
say? Well, let's go read the JSON object
first. I'm back in the office today. Oh,
you want to see? Yeah. So, it says
Received gifts from Ron Shangle who is
affiliated with NB USA, supplier,
business partner of Enron.
Cool. That looks like that looks like
something could be done. And what's
really interesting about this whole
workload is we notice that from a scale
of 10,000 emails, there's not that many
that are high risk. So you could
actually just build a loop that has a
human in the loop that tells, hey, I'm
going to build a dashboard that looks
and filters for all of these and then a
human will go and evaluate whether these
actually are bad or not. And now we've
Yeah. So that was that was kind of my
last question. is like, okay, we found
one that actually looks like the element
is doing what we want. How do we bake
this into our golden set so that as we
change the prompt and evolve the
pipelines, we can keep track of whether
this one's like obviously the visually
eval of what's the diff, but also just
the like we should check to make sure
that this email always gets a high risk
level that we can just evaluate
deterministically. I know we're getting
close on time. Um, but like do you want
to spend a minute doing that? I would
just literally make a test case for this
email that says that, hey, this email
just does that and that's it. See, I
love that. Like everyone tries to over
complicate this
stuff. Test pipeline.
Yeah. And then you can literally write
like deaf uh exactly test
pipeline or like test test that specific
email that you
have and you can just put the path to
the email. Exactly.
Um, put the path for this email instead.
That's what I would do. Yeah. I got to
find it though.
[Music]
Um, there you go. I don't think it's
gonna It will not grab. You'll have to
grab for that.
Um, just grab for the message ID.
Oh, yeah. Good idea, man. All these
random tips and tricks. Yeah. Like I
think people highly highly underestimate
how how important it is. But the most
important thing that everyone needs to
do is just like get really fast at this.
Great. Now we have a path. Exactly.
Cool. Exactly. So now you would just
like for test and test cases. Exactly.
Import
check. Yep. Uh risk level. There you go.
And if you look at the result that
should be assert result is not
none. Import
piest. Exactly. Uh and then import
piest.
Yep.
And really you should make a
parameterized test case, but that's
okay. Yeah, sure. That's fine. Just
highlight it and cursor will change it
for you. Yeah, there you
go. Cool.
Yeah. And now you just run pi
test. Oh, you need to mark it. Oh,
whatever. Let's see if it
works. Oh. Uh,
why is it I wonder if it's collecting
files from all of the data. Oh yeah, C
and just pass it to specific directory.
Yeah.
Um, Unexpected indent. Oh, tap tap.
Yeah, come on.
Cursor C routine object async.
Yeah. And you have to import uh pi test.
Oh, maybe. Yeah. A dash async.io. It's
dash.
Yeah. Uh you have to mark it at
piest.mmark.
Yeah. Yeah. Yep. Now it'll work. And
then we got to await it. Oh, yeah. Oh,
wait.
Um Oh, you have to actually load the You
loaded the path. You have to actually
load the
path. Think you have to load the email.
Oh, is this just the text? Okay. Yeah.
Like
load.
Yeah. There you go. And you probably
have to give it data slash I think.
Yeah, there you go. Yeah, tab. The data
thing was also correct on line six.
there you go.
Let's see. Amaron
cursor. Okay, so this is our
deterministic eval. Can we also make a
vibe eval? Exactly. Like a visualizer.
Notice what we did, right? We we started
off with a vibe eval. Then we got real
data. When we looked at the real data,
we're like, cool. This one when we
looked at it should always be correct.
So how are we going to do this? And we
did what you did which is like okay now
we did a little bit of extra work to go
write this code and it takes 5 10
minutes but if you keep doing this over
and over again now you have better and
better systems. And so there's like two
dimensions that we're exploding around
here. um which like I would love to chat
more about like how to do this at scale
but it's like there's the dimension of
like finding all the test cases for this
just this gift policy just one rule in
our policy set and getting that really
really good and then there's doing that
again you know squaring the uh input
space for every single policy that we
might care about and that's I think
probably highlights why like this is how
you do it and get really good quality
and that highlights probably why just
like ramming out a bunch of questions
from a policy document is probably less
less less useful than but notice the way
that we got the give policy is you ran
that process already and then you're
like okay this policy seems like one
that we can tackle like yep and notice
what I did what one of the things I
forced you to do was I forced you to
basically ignore all the other questions
we said we're just going to talk about
gifts today
like we actually we just said we're only
going to talk about gifts because we
could have spent this whole time talking
about just policies and we would have
gotten no Yep. But now that we feel
pretty good about that's like really
good. So now let's bump it up even
further. Can you go back to your code?
Yeah. Where do you want to go? Let's run
100,000 emails. Oh, okay. But now you'll
notice that this is going to be kind of
annoying. So yeah, make it 100,000. But
this is going to be kind Don't run it.
Don't run Don't run it. Um, this is
going to be kind of annoying. So like
this is another thing that I would do.
Um, how do I how do I cursor? H how do I
ask cursor? Uh, command K. Oh, yeah.
Sorry. Use um
what is TQDM?
It's great.
That's great. You'll see. We're use TQDM
to go do this.
Um, I think this will be pretty good,
but I'm going to do a couple more things
just to make this slightly better. Now
that we're running 100,000, I'm just
going to mark this
as Oh, you're just going to log out the
exceptions.
Well, I'm just going to say
like if it
fails, that's okay. We want to return
like gift email analysis or error or
none so that we can write it to a file.
Exactly. Called string or whatever.
Well, do you want the error message
basically? I don't really care. Okay.
I'm just And I think I have to return
this as well. Yeah. What I'll just
return a false specifically a false.
Okay.
Um, and there's only one type of error
that I'm actually going to catch, which
is Oh, sorry. Imported from the wrong
thing.
I basically only want to capture like
validation errors and if they happen
um I basically just want to ignore them
and return false.
Okay, I don't want to think about it.
Oh, I have to use literal
false. Just return literal error is
fine.
Um,
and then you want to log out the number
that have errors here. Exactly. So I
want to say like
cursor should figure this out.
Okay. What's TQDM? Are you going to tell
us and then let's let's run this one
last time and then let's do 15 minutes
for questions and we'll let people go.
Exactly. Run it. Run it. I think this
will work. What is this? Just run it.
Just run it. Trust me. All right. All
right. All right. And turn off your turn
off your terminal
TKDM in theory. This should work. Oh,
cool. It's just like a progress bar.
Exactly. Why does this not work the way
I thought it would? The progress bar
didn't do what I was supposed to. We
should cancel
this. While this is cancelling, let's
update the progress bar so it actually
does the right thing. Can you update the
progress bar so it does the right thing?
Um, what I will do
is So, let me write this down really
fast. Go ahead.
You got to like chunk it or something. I
don't
know. How does this work? Uh, I have to
ask cursor fix this. I forgot how to
the world's best prompt engineer and the
only thing you know how to tell cursor
is fix this and make it better. Yeah,
there you go. Uh, there you go. I think
this will work.
There you go.
Yeah. So, and and why do we do this?
Like who was um who was asking this is
like how do we be running this? Like
Charlie was asking how long will it
take? Now we have an approximate mental
model of how it's going to take too.
We're processing 100,000 emails
um and we know roughly how long it's
going to take by running this through.
And this is like something that a lot of
people don't do. But again, small thing
like adding the progress bar makes it so
we're not waiting forever. With 10,000,
we're like, "Ah, it's not that bad. So,
let's just go run this." With 100,000,
that no longer becomes feasible. So,
like I really want to have a good proxy
for like how how far along are we?
What's going on? What are the metrics
that are happening? Um, and if you're
not investing time in this kind of stuff
while you're iterating, again, it feels
slow in the moment, but now you see that
we're moving a lot
faster because like we know
approximately what we're waiting on,
what we're not waiting on.
Cool. That's dope. Should we open it for
questions? Yeah, let's wait. I I kind of
want to see the results of what
happened. Let's see the results. All
right. Um, let's add Let's look at the
results. Let's find one that's legit.
And let's add one more test case. Risk
level high. Financial donation to
cultural arts while seeking approval.
God damn, these people are all over the
place. All right, we'll we'll drop this
one in. Um, that's crazy. And I think
this what's great about the system like
yeah it did find something out.
we didn't find that one.
Um but this is kind of why I was saying
when you save stuff to disk it's just
not as good because like now capturing
this whole information is very very
hard.
Yeah. I mean, we could just like copy
this into a test cases folder probably
what we would do. Like, you're not going
to commit the entire set of emails or
whatever, but
um but yeah, this is kind of the this is
kind of um the interesting stuff that we
get to go do. Um any and then you can
imagine a UI around this really really
working really nicely. Exactly. Um cool.
I'm going to stop sharing. Um we can pop
back to the whiteboard if needed. But uh
what questions do folks have? So
question one from Andrew. This is all
assumed GT40 Mini. Did you vibe consider
other models? Um, I think it was 40 for
the record, but yeah. Yeah, I think we
could have considered any model, but
honestly, it didn't matter. What we
really wanted to go work on this time
was just whether or not this problem
could be solved. If the problem can't be
solved, it doesn't matter what models
can and cannot do it. So, we just want
to invest time in that sort of workload
first. And once we know it's good and we
know it's good enough, once we get more
vibes about it, then we can worry about
making the model smaller. Yeah. And if
we notice like, hey, the model really
sucks at finding ones that really should
be detected, then we'll use 03. We'll go
up to a bigger model. Exactly.
Uh, let me jump in, guys. Um, also
awesome, by the way, to watch you two
like wizarding all over the code. It's
really nice today. Um, what what would
be like the next steps from here? Like
how how would you what would you think
about doing after this? Well, the next
step is really to figure out how you're
going to process like five million
emails because processing five million
emails is not going to work with any
rate limit that we have. We did some
basics with parallelism on this. But
what I would do is I would say probably
need Amazon SQSQ or something of that
order of magnitude. Go process that
through and you just churn data at some
cadence and then you just sample real
production data like what Dex was doing
where he would like would look at the
file and just say like let's just look
at the high data and see if it looks
right. Let's look at the med medium
data. See if it looks right. Let's send
some random sample of the low data to
GPT4 uh G3 and just see maybe it missed
something. Um and it's really just like
going and building a metric for the
pipeline. And I wouldn't go ahead out of
my personally I wouldn't go ahead out of
my way to make the pipeline way way
better and way perfectly more accurate.
I just want to know approximately how
good it is. And once you have the core
of it, then I think you switch really to
like a test-driven development mode
where you're eyeballing stuff. And like
I think what you showed last week of
visualizing the diff and the drift is a
great way to quickly find new things
that should be test cases. And then what
you do is you say, "Cool, that should be
a test case that and you build a
pipeline to do that and add your test
cases. And then once you have more test
cases that that don't pass, then you can
go make the pipeline better." Or once
you wake up one morning and you're
spending $50 a day on open API to open
AAI tokens, then you go and say cool
like what's the bottleneck here? Which
step is spending the most tokens? Yeah.
And and really or you say this policy is
good enough. Let's move on to policy the
next policy.
Like we spent an hour built a pretty
decent giftgiving policy. Doesn't have
to be perfect. It's just good enough.
Caught some real scenarios that looked
high risk and instead of taking the
policy to like 100% I just put a human
in the loop in my process and I can
solve my software. Yep. And my favorite
and my favorite actual takeaway of this
is like most of this was not prompt
engineering. Like spending a day
building a perfect prompt and catching
every case is actually like way less
productive than setting up the rails and
the pipelines and the testing
infrastructure and the eval
infrastructure. So that when it comes
time to change your prompt, you know
exactly what you're doing and why you're
doing it. And you're not just vibing
like, "Hey, I think we should put the
things in this order instead of that
order because I read it in some [ __ ]
blog post.
Yes. And oh, another question on today
is like you were searching just on gift
in the emails. Like what would be
another way to do it or like the the
risk is that you don't find like it's
lab or it's labeled something else like
what would be another way of doing that?
I mean you could use embeddings are way
faster than passing every single one
through an LM. You could pass every
single one through an LM but again
that's more expensive. Um I don't know.
What do you got?
Um, yeah, but I think that most people
should just be looking at the data
first. Like just read like I I noticed
Dex this time too. Like instinct until I
like forced him to stop and read the
email. He didn't really do it. Um, and
like there's no amount of evals that we
could have done on that pipeline until
he just read the
email. Um, it would have been useless
effectively and like just slow down and
read look at the freaking data. Cool.
Amazing. Thanks all for hanging out. All
right. Thanks everyone. Have a good one.
Catch you all next week.